un claude blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales bonsoir claude
blanchemaison merci d'être avec nous à
distance pourquoi le président trame
prend cette décision de la chaise vide
l oms maintenant je crois que le
président sommes d'abord s'expriment
tous les jours par conséquent il faut
qu'ils aient des choses à dire et il ya
huit jours il a fait un véritable
réquisitoire contre le directeur général
de l'organisation mondiale de la santé
alors simplement hier il a tiré les
conséquences
il avait dit je le ferai et bien hier il
l'a fait c'est bien sa manière c'est à
dire qu'il a dit suivant
l'administration américaine de suspendre
la contribution de 400 millions quatre
cent quelques millions de dollars à
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
et puis nous verrons dans 90 jours
une fois une enquête conduite quelle
sera la décision définitive
non je crois que le deuxième motif le
premier c'est donc je lui dis je le fais
le deuxième c'est évidemment le degré d
entre eux peut être critiquée sur sa
gestion un peu erratique de la crise
sanitaire ses mac os vizir et que par
conséquent il fallait un bouc émissaire
le bouc émissaire est tout trouvé c'est
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
c'est son directeur est derrière les
liens il suppose avec avec les chinois
par conséquent il a évoqué mi ser et il
peut effectivement poursuivre ses
conférences ses conférences et oman air
où il y avait beaucoup de choses y
compris des choses qui sont parfois des
contrevérités et puis enfin évidemment
c'est une occasion pour lui de taper sur
une organisation générale et par
conséquent de désengager les états unis
du nord et d'australie l'a déjà fait
pour l'unesco il le fait pour les
traités multilatéraux et il va le faire
sans doute pour l'organisation mondiale
de la santé
et puis enfin je pense que son électorat
considère que
c'est une bonne chose donc dans son
électorat de base
ça lui rapporte plutôt des voix alors
qu'elles ont été au club en raison à les
réactions internationales cette décision
palais l'action internationale on était
assez prévisible
d'abord reçu ou terrestre c'est pater
générale de l'onu
évidemment dit que c'était pas du tout
le moment il fallait au contraire que
tout le monde sally pour lutter contre
la pandémie et notamment la seule
organisation internationale qui s'occupe
des questions de santé
l'om est ce n'était vraiment pas le
moment d'affaiblir oms
s'il ya des réformes à faire on pourra
en discuter après mais aujourd'hui
évidemment c'est une mauvaise manière
et c'est un peu ce qu'a dit aussi
monsieur le drian
le ministre français des affaires
étrangères sur la même ligne
monsieur josette borel haut représentant
pour les affaires étrangères et la
sécurité à bruxelles et le ministre le
ministre allemand donc effectivement des
regrets et une certaine incompréhension
je crois que certains hauts
fonctionnaires à genève ont également
dit nous ne comprenons pas on ne rompt
pas où il veut tout dire ou le
prétendent états unis votants dire dans
cette affaire puisqu'il faut lutter et
un moment où il ya vingt-six mille morts
aux etats-unis et où la pandémie net en
aucune manière maîtrisée où le président
doit discuter avec les gouverneurs pour
savoir quel est le degré de confinement
ou de reprise du travail qu'il faut il
faut accepter
alors quel rôle l'eau à metz at elle a
joué dans la crise pour le moment et
surtout évidemment la question qu'on se
pose quel rôle sans les états unis
je pense que il ya toujours un rôle
important qui sera joué dans la
coopération internationale dans ce
domaine
d'abord l'om est émet des avis le
directeur général de l' oms
le docteur me voyais tous dit tous les
jours il faut tester il faut et c'est
davantage il faut tester au maximum pour
séparer ceux qui sont affectés par le
virus et ce qu'ils ne sont pareil pour
isoler ceux qui le sont c'est une
recommandation du directeur général de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
et puis sujet qui est devant nous c'est
le sujet africain bien entendu l'afrique
qui n'est pas du tout équipés sur le
plan sanitaire va avoir probablement une
explosion de ce corps d'un virus dans
les prochains jours dans les prochaines
semaines et tous les pays s'en préoccupe
l'om est en particulier l'om est à
environ six mille médecins qui
travaillent pour elles et dont beaucoup
sont en afrique
par conséquent ils sont très utiles pour
les états africains qui ont à lutter
contre ce que rollin virus vous savez
que par ailleurs les décisions qui ont
été prises dès hier par le g7 et qui
aujourd'hui a été complété par le g20 et
qui consiste à effacer le service de la
dette des pays les plus pauvres dont la
plupart sont en afrique il non c'est pas
ça qui va arrêter là virus mais c'est un
soulagement pour les gouvernements qui
sont endettés qui sont très endetté et
qui ne peuvent pas acheter les
équipements sanitaires voulu d'ailleurs
la chine assez prononcé à l'intérieur du
g20 pour cette non pas cette remise de
dette à laquelle il faudra sans doute
arriver mais cette remise du service de
la dette c'est-à-dire du paiement des
intérêts je pense que effectivement dans
les semaines et les mois qui viennent le
sujet sera la remise de dette aux pays
les plus pauvres et notamment aux pays
africains
et puis sur le plan européen cette
semaine après tous les pays européens on
puisse mettre d'accord sur un fond qui
par plusieurs canaux abouti a rassemblé
500 milliards d'euros pour aider les
entreprises européennes
à faire face à la crise économique parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de morts dans la crise
du coronavirus mais pourrait y en avoir
encore plus dans la crise économique
par conséquent il faut également la
traiter c'est une urgence absolue
est ce que dans cette affaire les états
unis kipré qui préside le g7 prendront
les initiatives d'ici cet été
c'est possible mais monsieur trump elle
en préparation puisque manifestement il
n'aime pas les solutions multilatérales
et qu' il ya le plus grand mal à
maîtriser la pandémie chez lui aux états
unis d'amérique
merci co2 blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales